i gotta ask this what was it like
working with steve
jobs i didn't work with him did you
interact with him
twice i said hi to him twice in the
cafeteria
what did he say hi he said hey fellas
he was friendly he was wandering around
and
with somebody he couldn't find the table
because the cafeteria was
was packed and i gave my table but i
worked for mike colbert who talked to
like mike was the unofficial cto of
apple
and a brilliant guy and he worked for
steve for 25 years maybe more
and he talked to steve multiple times a
day
and he was one of the people who could
put up with steve's let's say brilliance
and intensity
and and steve really liked him and steve
trusted
mike to translate the he thought up
into engineering products at work and
then mike ran a group called platform
architecture and i was in that group
so many times i'd be sitting with mike
and the phone would ring
it'd be steve and mike would hold the
phone like this because steve would be
yelling about something or other
yeah and he would translate it and he
translated and then he would say
steve wants us to do this so
was steve a good engineer or no i don't
know he was a great idea guy
idea person he's a really good selector
for talent
yeah so that seems to be one of the key
elements of leadership right
and then he was a really good first
principals guy like like somebody say
something couldn't be done and he would
just think
that's obviously wrong right
but you know maybe it's hard to do maybe
it's expensive to do maybe we need
different people you know there's like a
whole bunch of you know if you want to
do something hard
you know maybe it takes time maybe you
have to iterate there's a whole bunch of
things
you could think about but saying it
can't be done is stupid
you